this is a production of cornell
university
all right guys so you're here at the
first ever botanical fashion show for a
martial arts horticulture class
three students have made designs to show
you all today sheila gordon um jasmine
laquisier
and eva johnson
right now i have my grass skirt on i'm
lulu rios
and
this
part of this skirt is designed with
peniceptium
foxtail so it's an annual form of this
grass and then i've alternated the
colors i think these are the less ripe
ones and these are the more ripe ones
and so that gives a design
and then the background of this skirt is
detailed with protonia
the leaves of this grass and then on the
back
have
creating a whimsical look perfect for a
wedding garden if you look closely you
might notice a hint of blue which is
noticeable on the top such a dress must
have something blue
finding a dress with seams and bonding
in place that can support the weight and
layer sewn onto the dress base of the
challenge jasmine recalled a blue polka
dot dress last morning high school
perfect to work from
once the bodice was feathered with
leaves and moss sewn in jasmine
carefully positioned the double layer of
the tulle wrapped around the waist
covered the skirt it was time to
determine how best to dust the whimsical
layer in the scratch jacket weave and
tie it with the acid wire
finally the tool was cut into strips and
fed through opening the shoes and head
piece
which complement the dress
for a total look
um
if you look closely at the back of the
head piece you can notice the dream
catching
yeah
the dream catcher is made of laguarus
ovitus which is full thread cred ammobia
and white feathers
were intended to seem as though they
were containing the laborer it is almost
as if the plants themselves were
constructing the worker so dependent are
the laborers on these crops
for a day's wage that unfair labeled
practices within the workplace can
remain unchallenged for some time
the bag is covered with arbor vieta
leaves and insinuated with countless and
plants five
and now we're gonna have our guests we
have nina basic from the art health
department and she works with men's
garden which is where i got all of the
flowers from
um
perspective
well i'm very
enjoy the fact that you use grasses
which might be seem to be gradual but
quite
tough yeah right and so
that's quite a big thing and i like the
whole composition and then oakley is
your idea yeah they're
yes so we took oak leaves and i didn't
glitch it myself i ordered them before
yeah okay and then there's progress
there's more of those as well
yeah yeah
issues
my name is charlotte and we have
charlotte from the textile department so
clothing
well i like i like the composition very
much
as nina said it's a complete look
you have the
headwear you have the dress you have the
footwear so it all goes together nicely
and i think
the wedding theme
it has a fresh look it has almost a hint
of innocence and hope for the future so
it's really a perfect combination
and then your colors you have a hint of
green in your headdress and then the
green
the gradation of dreams is really nice
i like the mix of textures so the the
elf flakes are really terrific for
bringing out the the texture and then
that
next to the the green that you wasted
especially so it's a really fun outfit
yeah and
you're just going to have to
take this
to uh greater heights we should have had
the tv folks here
in the video
very nicely done thank you
and i was wondering if anyone in the
class had any questions um the oakley's
at the top you turn them
like
they're like vertically placed yeah
they're upright and i sewed around like
the main
vein
um
and yeah so i just did like like three
little
sewing sutures i guess down the vein and
then these are already prepared
yeah because they're dried they like
naturally kind of like curled up a
little bit
yeah which material you find is
difficult to work with um the grass for
sure because
um
i originally wanted to just glue the
grass onto the dress
um but this grass is a lot thicker than
the one that i planned or wanted to use
so what i ended up having to do was like
sew it on to like an
individual piece of wire and like wrap
like bunches of them and then sew it
onto the dress so it was a lot more
work than just like
like hot gluing it on
so this was harder
um i
have so much leftover material from like
what i ordered and last night i
um
wanted to make one because one of my
best friends made one um from my
leftover material and so i looked up how
to do it and i decided that it looked
great with the dress and it's all the
same theme so i had it in the back
um were there grasses like already
curled like that no they were straight
they're like one of the straight like
bushes of um
grass
out there and uh
i actually got injured
like two weeks ago and couldn't like
walk and so i needed like space in my
room so i couldn't correctly dry them
flat on the floor so they ended up
drying in a bucket and kind of got the
curly look which i ended up liking
so
um it
took me the entire fall break and then
like
at least two to three hours a day since
then so
yeah
is is this permanent i mean once you
take it off are things going to start
falling off it's pretty permanent i put
it on like three different times and
like i think this is what's gonna end up
staying
and like
yeah everything's pretty much preserved
so
yeah i think it'll stay for a while
well we're final round
i thought it was so interesting that you
chose to do a costume
workers who were being exploited
i honestly don't remember why i want to
do that
i think i was walking by the banana
plant and welcome me the welcome center
and wow those leaves are really big and
that'd be really cool to work with but
next time i make the dress i have plants
and we'll make it out of leaves though
so it was a good idea for
coming out either exploited worker from
um
actually it was interesting working with
the materials because these tobacco
leaves came from some of some family
friends
in like haiti in the dominican republic
and so i used to live in the dominican
republic and i just was talking to my
friend one day and she was like oh what
are you up to and i was like i have this
really cool horticultural project she's
like you know like we still have an
implementation can you just shift you up
and he
was like that'd be great like are they
gonna be dry by the time they get here
and she's like no no they stayed like
pretty pliable for a couple weeks so
it's like awesome send them up and they
were very pliable and i was just telling
them that i was trying this on this
morning like making sure i could like
bend my arms and things like that and
things were good and then i brought it
out into the windsor this morning
so so we have cotton and tobacco
there are coffee beans on the head wrap
yeah and the banana leaves
so actually the head wrap is the bin
that we made
so
it has natural plants
as i know it was
really a very unusual
theme and
execution
i find it interesting too that you're
looking at cultural and social and
political
emphasis with your costume and in fact
closing through the ages has done that a
bit you know
in the days when women wanted to
present themselves as stronger figures
and they put shoulder pads in their
suits and i'm sure you all have heard
that before but but you know in order to
make a statement that women were strong
and they could handle these jobs like
men and so forth and
so i think it's interesting that you're
sort of carrying on that tradition i'm
definitely not an artist so i i wanted
to i started with research and i kind of
wanted to just go with something that i
can learn
you've also done a really good job of
creating the look of 18th century uh
costumes like it it came out looking
ragtag you know like
i don't know they were like i said the
leaves stretched across the whole dress
and like like everything was covered
before
so it looked a little fresher and now
that it's dried i mean like you can see
the cloth but if i had put more on it
like knowing that they were going to dry
up in a day then it would be interesting
to see what it would look like more
ragged and things like that but i think
the the tobacco leaves actually have a
certain mustard to them so it actually
if you're at a distance it could look
like satin or silk or you know weighted
silk that is interesting because the
leaves that i received in the middle
like one side of them was a more
golden mustardy color and then the other
side was a very deep almost purpley
brown
so i had a hard time deciding which one
i wanted to use but it ended up being
that the leaves curled a certain way
that was conducive to painting them onto
the dress and things like that so most
of them are
the lighter tan color but i really like
the dark
and i may be one of the few people in
this room has actually worked in a
tobacco field so i know a lot about
those leaves
and i was interested in the banana
leaves too
i'm sure you know that you can scrape
those banana leaves and get actual
fibers which then you can we were doing
so that's really interesting too anyway
it's a very fascinating concept
any questions from class
so if people were curious about your
source of the tobacco leaves you said
you ordered them
yes i ordered them from
well it's my father's friend who lives
in port prince
and a couple from my friend in
santa domingo republic but most of them
are from the plantation like right
outside
i also just have a comment even though i
grew up in upstate new york my
grandfather grew tobacco and hung it in
his attic to dry
and eva had this sword in my office this
morning and it was you know scent is so
connected
it's like
entering my grandparents house is really
really good
less right now that it wasn't received
yeah yeah my mom is completely
substantial tobacco and my ra came in
the other day was like are you rolling
cigars
they're actually from here
from the plantations yeah
yeah so
a couple of them are from
a
compost bin which
someone who works in the greenhouse i
don't know if you know where the
arboretum is
near
do you guys
go
know
what
the welcome center and things like that
um there's a green house that was about
to compost a lot of banana leaves
um and
i had caught her up the exact right time
because the next day she was going to be
putting my husband so she was
so i got some from there and then
um yeah that's where most of them are
it was it was a
it was an excursion getting them up like
i had
planned to like bike there and i had
like a backpack to stuff them all in and
then like i got a flat going by funky so
i was like all right i have to meet her
in 15 minutes from west campus so i'm
gonna run and i like ran really fast
good stories
i do think that under on the back of the
address you have to put a label though
that mentions the flammability
you said you'd done a lot of research
before you started designing the dress
and i was just wondering why you picked
this specific time period i don't i
don't know i think the first thing that
triggered it was
the banana leaves outside of the welcome
center like i said and i was on a run
with one of my friends
and
she is colombian and was talking about
coffee or her grandparents like
harvesting coffee beans or something
like that and then we started talking
about how the store banana republic is
not the first time that term has been
used and banana republic was really like
started
in
like referring to
like guatemalan
unfair trade practices and things like
that with big business there um and so i
think it was just a mixture of like her
and i go and buy the banana plants and
then we walked by banana republicans
stay at the mall and i was like well
that'd be kind of
weird to do a dress like that
so i think that's what it
to be the queen
because i just think
you have to do this kind of wave i mean
you didn't do this it was like
you started almost not moving your wrist
so it was the bag
yes well now six actually because the
dress also so is it the bag the gloves
the hat the shoes and the necklace
right
thanks so much
so the leaves were mostly hemlock
designer
um on the dress and the handbag yeah
that must have been difficult to
get on everything a lot i mean
there's pretty small leaves it looks
like it's totally covered
what this leaves what are there beans
so that was part of it as well
so there must be something under there
that you included onto but
well the dress itself and then i moved
them onto the dress
it was looking very different from this
now everything's falling apart
i love the maple leaves
color
of course the queen tends to be
some kind of monochromatic you know
she's always like blue pastel pink
green
and
it's very
impressive i'm just wondering if we can
call this queen within her salad
looks green
so first of all it's a tremendous amount
of work and you can see that all those
beans and we even have beans in the
necklace yes are those wired on or those
are hatchimals
actually um the necklace itself came
from the hat so the hat came with some
pores around it
so i initially wanted to do a malleable
pine twig
but it wouldn't work over the hat so i
just took the cords off the hat and then
just put the mask around it glued it on
and then glued
the beans onto it and did some
multicolored beans on the end
it's quite impressive your hat um that's
the moss from you so that that actually
looks like a lot of the other materials
that we use every day you know something
like polar fleece even that's made from
the soda bottles
and then also a wool of felt
so that you could take the wool fibers
and
by adding moisture and agitation and
heat then you get this felted fabric and
that's what your half looks like so you
really achieve the look of the material
that people are familiar with but yeah
you're using something really creative
and innovative
what what is that
feather thing in your hand
it's um it's dried white pine needles
that's that's really that's really crazy
i actually sew it onto the hat
so i sewed it on and then i put the
beans over it to hide it right
just
then i put them onto the hat and then i
just
you know around the needle and break
through the height of your time
pack them on there and then just make a
pattern over here
here's some really interesting
structures too on your
on your handbag
is that twining or braiding that goes
around the light color it's flying fiber
blind fiber um we made some stuff in
class and i am asked the professor for
some leftovers that she had what's that
rambia yeah i
the contrast of the textures that you
get by the different techniques so the
moss looks like a non-woven fabric and
then you've got what looks like twining
or grading around the purse you've got
the flat application
that we might do when we're appliqueing
anything on the garment so you really
mix the textures and the structures
and does the class have any questions
how did you get the gloves
well on started with this one first and
then i just kind of changed my way out
um it's weird because when i was doing
it at home
i knew i got this one right and then for
some reason i thought i had this one
right now and i just put it on i
realized
no i'm from jamaica but jamaica was once
colonized by england so i don't know the
idea in my head
are you familiar with the phrase
it's like that
it's a cherry thing and
men and women dress up in these clothes
that are like covered with like pearls
and beans and beads
and it just looks like that's like an uk
tradition
well i i went online and actually looked
up some pictures of queen elizabeth
so i i mean being colonized by indian i
already know that you know she has a
glove single and a necklace
but i know that um
she wore a variety of hats sometimes
they're really broad sometimes they're
like this so
i just chose this one and
made it look like her
where did you get all the different
materials from did you collect a lot of
them yourself i did it was painstakingly
hard
all these materials are from the
property actually there's a great
gentleman named phil who actually helped
me um he took me to the sources and
actually showed me where they were
i think it's on mall drive or somewhere
i don't know what the name is right just
below bb hall there's like a plantation
here right there so i had to go there
and [ __ ] and cut them
oh my shoes yeah well um
i i sprayed the glue on there and then
well this was probably i don't know
i stuck up the other morning until
probably like almost three o'clock
i went down to the garden and i picked
some hemlocks like branches of them and
then i came home and stripped them off
like a little tiny hemlock where you
guys actually stripped them off into a
bag
so i went to bed like three o'clock then
then i woke up the next day and i
sprayed the glue on and then just um
you know sprinkle the hemlock leaves
over and then just
put some cones along the top
any more questions
well it's supposed to be a brush because
the queen always wear bro
so but i just put mine for this s for me
sheila
another round
right now wonderful
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu